there you know what the zip code was
where i grew up 913.
that's how old i am we had the other two
numbers yet
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to
oh my god hi
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george lopez george lopez oh my god
omg omg hi oh my god
hi
great today's uh george's guest today
is an award-winning writer director
filmmaker
lorena gordon ladies and gentlemen
you know what that's awful yeah okay
today's guest
but you know you didn't mention her film
or any i thought you were gonna i
thought we were gonna like tag team and
i thought you were going
there i thought you were like hey by the
way i'm in this movie what are we
the [ __ ] bobsled team like the you i
turn the wheel and you follow behind me
you nestle in next to me
we're on the two-man luge let's do it
again okay if we got two men lose
who's the top i call top
uh today's george's guest today is an
award-winning director writer
producer filmmaker she has many
movies out that she's produced all by
herself and i believe
that you young lady
will get an academy award nomination for
at last
hi i feel i feel like the things that
need to happen
in order for something like that to
happen are falling in line it's like
when your mom plays the lottery and she
gets
zero numbers right and she's like nope
nope
nope nope nope tear the paper there's a
there's a certain sequence of things
that have to happen
in order for somebody to win at like
plinko
on prices right um
i didn't see that one coming i thought
michael was some kind of
some kind of uh an academy film academy
i didn't know about
maybe but it's just a game on praise is
right remember plinko
yes bling was great um
yeah and you know i asked you before
when we weren't on that i really don't
want to make this about
you know how we met or how i mean the
process of the film but also want to
know
a little bit about about
your life because i met your mom right
yeah
at the shoot and your brother and my
brother yeah so
where would if i ask you instead of him
over here
um how would you best define
yourself in in in way in the way of this
film like how what
how did you get there and where did you
start sure first of all thank you guys
for the invitation i'm so
happy to be here i thought it was
important because you know i i just feel
like you know this is a very special
uh project and you've got a lot a lot of
important people involved behind the
scenes and in front of the camera and
there's you know
at a time right now when
you know when you ask somebody or you
get asked to do things like a hundred
times
you know 100 times this no it's like no
i don't want to do that nobody does
anything for anybody much anymore
because it's just like i don't know
you know you have like three days but
somehow two hours of those
you know 48 hours is just a pain he has
to do something so
um you wish more people had
each other's backs when it came to
someone
who's just starting in this business and
would benefit highly from
someone's expertise and that's and
that's what i think that
everybody gathered around um at last
yeah no absolutely so just to give you
kind of like a
synopsis of how i got to that point i
was born and raised in new york
and um always loved film i think i was
eight when i saw titanic like that was
the film that did okay so you always
loved film but
but was who in your family was
um into movies and was it theater as
well or just
or just movies no my grandfather was a
bullfighter
and my brother is into music so there
was no
you know movies or anything like that
but my mom and my brother somehow took
me
to the movie theaters to see titanic i
remember at the end when jack dawson
you drowned i was crying and as an
eight-year-old i was like
what is happening to me why am i being
moved by these
by these images and i didn't know there
was you know a
director and producer and i thought
movies just magically appeared you know
as a kid it's
you know magic pure magic once i knew
that this is something that people you
know it's an art form that people
do for a living that's when like the
switch
in my brain clicked and i was like okay
i want to tell stories
and i picked up a camcorder as a kid and
just started making these short films
with my cousins and throwing my brother
in there
and it was just well what year was that
too because that was because you know me
and you
you know we're like high eight what was
it called
like we had stuff that yeah super eight
super we didn't even have you know like
because what you're saying is what
steven spielberg did it's what every big
director does on the way up if robert
rodriguez did it
is when you use your friends you start
making horror movies and you start
making action movies
and so yeah so um maybe unbeknownst to
you you already like on the path
of of what great film makers and
directors do at that age
you wouldn't know yeah and at the time i
mean it was i was a shy kid growing up
you know i was like into movies this
weird awkward kid
and for many reasons um i was closeted
when i was younger and i think
being behind the camera helped me feel
less alone and like i could tell these
stories and like i said i i was super
shy and i didn't know how to express
myself and
through a camera i could do that it's
closeted uh shy
closeted means not out not out oh okay
yeah
like not at like i knew i was gay as a
kid you know
so that i felt alienated
different so that's you know
i was telling brian that i wanted to
discuss that because of all the things i
believe
and not only just in our community but
just in in
the narrow-mindedness of just of a
culture that
rewards beauty but doesn't do much for
people's the inside of people those
people would be considered weird or
stranger
you know like cartoon the the the artist
he said when he was like 14 because
all the guys he went to school with
couldn't draw and he could
that they made him feel weird for being
able to draw
and he didn't draw for 10 years because
because all those guys are like
well we can't draw like you so we'll
make fun of you for drawing
then you won't draw and then we'll all
be at the same level but wow
it eventually finds eventually finds
itself i think a few
so in in a situation like that like
do you remember when you knew or do you
know what
yeah i was about nine or ten years old
when i knew i was different i
there was no verbiage i didn't know you
know like i grew up catholic
you know my family is catholic so you
just know that that's
wrong and something i will or at the
time it was like something i'll never
you know bring up or experiment i'll
just keep that as a secret deep deep
down inside no one's
ever gonna know and when you and when
you went to school and you had your
friends like that did
did any of them i don't think they would
have known either right i tried
so hard to perform for them
and and make sure that in no way would i
could
or could i ever be outed by anyone so i
really
that's why it came to a point where it
so
again i'll add also to that factor so at
13 i was diagnosed with lupus which
is an autoimmune disease so here i am as
a 13 year old where
you know people are dating your body's
changing like all these things so it was
really shitty like the shittiest of
years i think was the my 13
you know and also dealing with my
sexuality and
but film always came in the forefront
and that was like
my um my therapy
my escapism growth or anything because i
noticed you're
probably like four and a half feet
though that has nothing to do with the
lupus or
being closer those are jeans george look
at my face just so i know
a lot of times you see like little
people you're like hey man what's going
on
when their hip and their ankle are a
foot apart
you know that you're like wait a minute
she's vertically challenged just
vertically challenged
all right um so so yeah so uh
sorry your question was um what was the
question uh
about your height but but did your
friends oh yeah okay so
oh yeah so then i come to a point where
um
i just i it became so exhausting and i
couldn't i couldn't keep up this
performance like it was just draining me
mentally and physically so you had to
pretend you were somebody else
everything that you did around your
family around your friends and do you
think like you said being outed
do you think that um because of bullies
and all that stuff in school like that's
another generation
were you worried are are people worried
about being outed
i was worried about not being first and
foremost it was my family's approval
that i was afraid you know my mom got
divorced when i was four years old you
know
it's been the three of us like she
helped raise myself
yeah gone um so it's it
for me i saw it as not adding another
burden for her
you know like the last thing she would
want is for her daughter to be gay
so that ends not being accepted so i
didn't
want to not be accepted by my family but
i mean so
it's got to be tough because you're
probably
like you said performing which is very
interesting so you're you're
you're acting like someone you're not
and then
maybe buying clothes that are clothes
that
you wouldn't necessarily because they're
gender specific
you know dresses and and things like
that and guy
and you know how it is specific now
there might be
you know different stuff uh but so
even to so from the from the time of you
waking up in the morning to the time
that you went to sleep the whole day was
a bit of a mask right
yeah for the most part yeah so the only
time i could
step away and not think of any of that
was while i was watching movies
and that's how it became like this thing
that i
eat breathe you know you love it
yeah yeah okay so
who who were your inspirations oh man
martin scorsese absolutely
um and then i had the honor to be a pa
on wolf of wall street
and i had the the the opportunity to
talk to him
you know everyone was super nervous
around him like don't look his direction
and all this thing and
i just went up to him one day and i was
just like you are such an inspiration to
me
and he was diagnosed with asthma as a
kid that's how he got into movie making
if you
yeah if you read his biography you know
um as a kid growing up in the east
in little italy you know kids are out
playing and stuff like that he had
asthma so he just watched movies because
he couldn't play out
you know play outside with friends um
and we were born in the same hospital
in flushing so uh yeah and i remember he
just said just
go make your your films and that was the
last project i ever
was a production assistant on and then i
moved out here to california
you know so there was a there was a
reason that you became the production
assistant there
how did that how did you become a pa for
it so
because i think everything is not a
coincidence like like everything is
kind of on your path yeah yeah so once i
graduated high school i you know
looked to go to film school i got
rejected by all the film schools so i
went to massachusetts for a year at this
liberal arts college
went there for a year and reapplied to
all the film schools that i had been
rejected from
and i got accepted to one in new york
and emerson college in boston
i felt homesick missing my family so i
went back to new york
and went to film school and
you know i think that's also something
that we need to destigmatize is like you
you know as soon as you go to
like after high school go to college
because sometimes that's not the path
for many people and i realized that
two semesters into my film school that
this wasn't my path
well you know i think it's really kind
of like
i mean it was around when i was growing
up that it just
for whatever reason everybody thought
that
if you graduate from high school in june
that in september you're starting at
university and you have that one
exactly summer and then you know the gap
year thing was like almost
incomprehensible people like you're
gonna miss a year of
potentially going to school when i think
when you graduate from high school if
there's
any time in your life that you really
don't know what to do with yourself
it's immediately after high school yeah
right back then you got the eyes rolled
where i'm gonna take a year off
uh okay i'm not gonna make it because
you know i when i was in high school
and you know i still hang out with those
guys and we were having a great time in
that summer
and then a little after labor day you
could see things really starting to just
kind of harden
and i remember being in my grandmother's
house
the first day of school and really the
first day that i didn't
go to school anymore and it was wild man
like you just felt
like this huge part of your life was
missing even though i didn't look like
school
it gave i mean you've been going for 12
years plus
and then all of a sudden that one
tuesday you
everybody's walking to school you're not
and
what you got to do with yourself for the
rest of your life so that's yeah i
i so in in being homesick out there like
how did that
manifest itself so yeah so i was in film
school
and i would i would um
just literally if there's one thing you
know about me i'll just like go for it
so i saw people
filming a movie and i went up to you
know the uh assistant director and i was
like what do i need to do to pa
and like you can get a pa job yeah it's
you know it's like
a pa is like brian but with a nice shirt
now you said that dude i go go bring me
two cats
i come out with scratches
[Laughter]
maybe some beef bats
yeah so i started paying on multiple you
know
projects while still going to school and
i remember i was coming to this point
where i was like i don't know
you know college is so expensive and i
was like i can't keep doing this and
i went to my production professor he was
the sound recorder
for um uh so he did sound for
the original exorcist and the godfather
like he's worked with coppola and all of
that and
just went up to him and i was like do i
do you think i need to do this because i
don't know if i can
keep coming to film school and he looked
me right in my eyes and he's like
you have it he's like just go do your
thing
oh wow and that was the
uh just like affirmation or confidence i
like
the confidence boost i needed to leave
film school obviously it disappointed my
mother
you know who her dreams are to see her
children graduate college and
so i do you think that's a thing or do
you just think her dreams are like just
to get
people to get them out of the house no
because there's one thing that the
pandemic is
taught that parents didn't realize how
how
big school is for getting your kids out
of the house and people choking kids now
and throwing them around
and that wouldn't be happening if school
was open you know
right because you don't realize that
sure they're learning
but you drop them off at 7 50 in the
morning you don't see them until four
you're like
oh what a relief yeah yeah but it wasn't
like you were telling your mom hey i'm
moving back in
yeah it wasn't like that that wasn't
stressful yeah yeah at this point
does your mo was your mother aware of
anything of of your life
no no just the fact that i i loved
movies and that's what i wanted to
pursue so
yeah i um but i think you'd be more of a
scorsese type person than
someone who's a little more like maybe
in the sci-fi and stuff right
oh yeah no i've always loved dramas and
really grounded in reality and grounded
in real behavior yeah okay
yeah i think the thing that i
if i were to step away from dramas it
would be comedies you know i would like
to in the comedy realm something a
little more
upbeat and happy but for me i know when
i watch a movie
um it and i feel moved you know and it
makes me think or makes me cry like
though
i yeah i absolutely love that let's use
let's take a little bit of a pause here
and go over what we know so far
because i think it's important for
even if kids don't listen to this for
parents to understand
that if you try to make somebody fit
into a box they don't fit in
it's you're going to have rebellion
and maybe a lot of those kids never
get to be successful in whatever
they're trying but at least trying is
better than letting that
window of time go by when you can't go
back and get that time
and then maybe later you realize and
then you tell your mom you know and your
dad
you guys never believed in me you never
trusted me you never let me make my own
decisions
you tried to plan my whole life for me
and it didn't work and i told you i
didn't want to do that
and i told you that i didn't want to do
this and still you made me do it and i
just
lost 10 years of my life trying to make
you guys happy
while i'm while i'm miserable
jennifer horvath
college acceptance speech work for work
so that so um but you
uh do you agree with that absolutely
yeah 100
because my grandfather would tell me
you're going to go tell lies and i would
just be like you know
it's like [ __ ] you don't need to hear
when you're going to do something where
you just feel like you're this one
little pin
and then this whole [ __ ] world of
movies and tv
and all that [ __ ] and the guy that lives
in the house with you is
every time you leave the house you to
tell some lies
yeah i think that that really impacts a
kid you know as to you know
and that's one thing i'm so grateful for
you know for my mother
to never had diminished my dreams you
know i told her you know when i was
11 years old like i want to win an oscar
like she would
my brother like never laughed in my face
you know so it's like that
i feel like it's it means it's
so powerful for a kid to know that you
know at least my family supports
you know and what year are we talking
about right now that we took
now that we're going everything what
year are we talking about because i
i got a feeling it's not that we're not
that far
from that right okay so like me when i
go
to talk about the past i remember seeing
[ __ ] windmills i mean who's that all
that you remember seeing
windmills don quixote running around
there or somebody selling the
encyclopedias door-to-door
or some the fuller brush man
how long i've been rather doing selling
brushes fuller brush man that's back
there you know what the zip code was
where i grew up
913. that's how old i am we had the
other two numbers yet
we didn't have area codes right we never
did what's your number that's seven
seven three fourteen
fifty-five all right i remember before
that before the 310 area code
and uh when the three window area code
came out my grandfather was like oh [ __ ]
okay so all right so then
now you move out here and then how is
that yeah
so i had made a short film which was my
first short film that i made
another personal film and that one is
based on my mom's experience with
domestic abuse and how she was able to
leave this
you know marriage for the sake of her
two kids and
we had shot that in new york and then
moved out here it did post-production we
got into a couple of festivals
shot that in new york so that was like
my my i wouldn't say my ticket but
everyone comes out here saying i'm a
right i'm a director i was like you're
not going to move until you have
something to show people
like this is what i do okay well you
don't nobody does that
nobody does something that they have to
take around like out here
i mean they got you know the thing that
you're working on the golf thing
have they created a little bit of a
sizzle where the guy's hitting golf
balls in here no they haven't
well no no nothing like that so so
having the
you know knowing that it's better to
have something done which is more
difficult because
even if you were to move out here you
could say to somebody well you know i
moved down i'm just getting my
just landing here but you wanted to have
some things somebody could see which is
a huge huge uh difference and then
putting that together though what kind
of project was that
you didn't have anything in your pocket
before you made that how was it to get
that done
how did that happen oh man that was
literally
myself and my brother you know who
produced that project and it
we crowdfunded that project as well and
you know i found two actors who
resonated with the material
and marlene was an angel because she was
you know i literally sent her an email
saying
can you please read this i would love
for you to be a part of it and um
yeah again having that person say yes i
see you
and i want to support you again immense
immensely
just impactful and um yeah we shot that
but not everybody told you yes people
that told you
oh yeah no no i'll get to all the no's
yeah yeah
no so it's those those things that
really
you know just helped bring that project
to life
and again just knowing what the vision
for that project was and once we
started sharing it with people you know
we got calls from
from shelter homes and these
organizations that deal with domestic
violence and at the time i was just
writing it i think because i wanted to
get it off my chest
and i had all these feelings towards my
father that i think i wanted to get on
the page that i didn't have the balls to
say to
did you know where your father was yeah
yeah no he was in our
in our life until i was 18 when i was
going to college and he came over
and you know my brother's like are you
going to say goodbye are you going to
help mom with some of the stuff that we
just
we just spent like five grand at bed
bath and he was like
no so uh yeah that was like the last
time i ever saw him and we ever had
conversations yeah
he was he was a bit of an [ __ ] yeah
yeah oh man wow
uh and he hasn't tried to reach out or
anything no no no
no yeah man you know um it's a really
difficult thing i mean
you know when and
i bet you probably felt different
because if your other friends have
mothers and fathers around and a bigger
family and you know you have that going
on
you know the abuse or you know the
yelling and hiding and
all the stuff that comes with that like
it just almost feels like it's
impossible
to get out from under that right yeah
and
and i was very fortunate to have my mom
and my brother you know my brother
is you know he took he he helped raise
me
so thanks to the amount of love
that they've shown i never felt like
there was this missing thing
i do like get super you know teary eyed
when i watch like
father and daughter stories and films
but other than that
you know i i feel like we've done pretty
well the three of us you know
since since then but also you know
if he stayed it would be more
destructive than if he left
i mean better that someone leave and not
have any contact
than someone leave and still manipulate
the people that he left behind
yeah and i feel like i've been watching
six man
you've been reading some books
oh my gosh
and i think it's informed me you know in
my stories that i tell you know and as
an artist
i feel like trauma and all these you
know relationships
does form you you know so you you i read
something that you
say you like to make movies about the
human condition is what you said
um and i'm wondering when you were a kid
you picked it up
and what were those movies about i want
to know what you guys think
let me tell you something that's the
worst [ __ ] question i ever heard
you just going around around circles so
can i ask you about that
you are going to go and be make a stand
do you remember standing up
did you ever making that stance no i
mean what you said you
you make really heartfelt movies yeah
and i'm wondering when you were a kid
what were those
about were those something about what
was going on that didn't come out later
that little kid catches the ball toward
the end forget it we had the kid with
the kid with the boogers anyone he's
been here at the end
um i can tell you some of my favorite
movie like the ones that made me cry
ghost i remember saying ghosts of course
did you cry a ghost
i did you did uh um no one knows but i
did okay
i was touching one one more white dude
gone i laughed
[Laughter]
again once you let your old lady get
over it
before you start showing up as a mist
you know white people they just they fly
and they breathe under water
they can't just you know they get mad
when latinos want to do a movie about
just life somebody's going to believe
that [ __ ]
they throw webs out of their palms come
on
horrible okay so anyways
back to my crappy question like when you
what you did make movies when you're a
little kid though you always had a it
was what i read you picked one up and
you were like
yeah yeah what was that what was that
what would you do
those are those are in a box in my
cousin's
house in new york buried away because no
one will
we used to act in them like we produced
them and i remember there was this one
that we shot in central park you know
where like all those rocks are in
central park
yeah so yeah they were just at that time
we were
it was i think less serious more just
you know action adventure because that's
the only way it could entertain these
like you know eight-year-olds
to one another i'm gonna say that if you
want if you wanted i mean there's so
many great film
people that come out of new york like
like it's just really all of it seems
like a set
you know central park and walking down
the street so if you're a young person
and you're
you live in new york and you're looking
at the bridge
and you're looking at it from different
angles just everything over there
it's so cinematic it is very cinematic
yeah
not like over here where you know you
stand in the corner and then you know
your cup pulls up right next to it
there's some complaints
by the watch so yeah so i do think
that yeah everything
has its place so coming from there i
think there's a good like
everything seems to be lining up yeah
yeah
so so yeah so then i had made that short
film and you know we played a couple
festivals but nothing really
it got picked up too and and that was it
and
then i started just living you know at
this time
i had come out so that was
i always tell people like a rebirth for
me because at this point now
i feel free that i can go and
date and experience what normal
i wouldn't say normal but like your
average teenager would do
in high school and like but now i'm i'm
doing this for the first time
ever so i felt a little late to the game
and
um was your birth did your brother know
so he was the first person i told so
this happened on valentine's day um
and i had just you know gone out on my
first date and it was a disaster and got
my heart broken and all of that
so going back to that um
moment where you just can't carry this
no longer i always compare it to like a
pressure cooker
you know where it's like about to go off
i had come to this point in my life
where
i just i couldn't do it i remember it
was um
well first i had seen um
elliot page had come out as gay and i
saw that speech word for word just i was
tearing up
just resonated with me so much i
grabbed my keys i went inside my car and
i called my brother at this time he was
living in new york so it was like
2 a.m his time and i just started crying
and he's like well you know are you okay
like what's going on and
i finally and that's where that scene
came from um
and i said you know i'm gay he's like i
know
and you know are you okay and and just
the most comforting words that you want
to hear you know in
at that time and um it's a
valentine's day i will never forget and
i'm forever grateful that
um even telling him was just so much
weight lifted off my shoulders
and knowing that things were going to be
okay because it was a very dark dark
place in my life
i feel um personally you know i i had
i had made my film but i wasn't happy
with who i was and
and how i was living you know here i was
telling people go follow your dreams go
bu
and i felt like such a hypocrite because
i'm not doing that
um so yeah and then and then next i i
came out to my mom
and um you know she cried but again said
i love you
and i just want i just i just hope that
the world
treats you with with with love and
kindness and
and and that's all
oh man i just think that you know
the society is so set up like it's so
structured
of really nothing is good or bad it just
is
everybody should be allowed to just be
who they are i think one of the things
that
the problem is in this society is where
you try to make everyone think the same
thing and even with the
canceled culture of things like if we
remove people
who have something to say then we're
going to end up listening to people who
have nothing to say
and those people you know for speaking
out get you know
attacked and removed you know not all of
it's valid but
in a world where we should speak freely
no one's going to if you know that
you're going to lose your job you're
going to lose your
identities your families your business
or whatever you know so
um yeah when you when
because i think this i mean every
culture but i think latinos too because
of the mail and the macho and the
all that stuff that if a kid is uh
you know closeted that in the in a
family
with i don't even say a strong male
thing it's just all
such a joke like the if someone is
closeted i'm sure you heard it all the
time it's just such a
that it's such a joke but yet people who
are
and i'm responsible as well but you
you don't realize the damage you're
doing to those people that
aren't out but are around hearing people
talk the way they talk
you're such an insensitivity towards
people who you know have big noses like
you
yeah and i have a friend who has a big
nose
[Laughter]
so yes right and and okay yeah because
and i think it has changed now but i
mean yeah
i feel you know it's all about just
uh educating and the more people i feel
that that come out
and maybe it's your uncle or your
teacher
i i hope to witness one day where it
doesn't have to be this conversation and
and no other kid has to feel like how i
did in that car when i was calling my
brother that i felt like
my world was over like this was like the
biggest secret i had kept and
now i'm releasing it and holy [ __ ]
that's how i felt basically yeah because
you know one of the reasons
i just admire you so much for being
diligent about what you
really want to do in life but i thought
it would be important you know
for us just starting this thing that i
think that your opinion
is valid in here like your free speech
but also where you came from like i
wanted to know but also i knew that
it wasn't easy for you and in our in our
culture
um that you can't even say you're sick
and people it's just like oh like
everything's a burden to people
even though they're like oh my stomach
doesn't hurt oh you know just everything
is so
the end of the world that you
dare not be honest with anyone that's
why i think
that you know people lie and they
are living lives and there's there's
only in the in the
one life you get to live no part of it
should be lived in a lie
yeah and that is what made you make at
last correct
yeah that's that's what's
[Laughter]
so i was thinking you know what can i
make i was getting you know this
urge to want to make something and what
is a story i
i felt like i had come to this point
where i came to accept myself i was
happy with who i was and i wanted to tap
into that and
i was just thinking about high school
how much i hated high school you know i
i played basketball you know
competitively since my senior year of
high school and
so i was like this freak like into
basketball
also into movies and music like i i did
i didn't fit in
anywhere um and you know i remember prom
specifically you know my mom was like
dolling me up with my dress
and my makeup and all of that and i just
remember being at prom you know in heels
and just i was like ah
yeah i just want to go you had a date
for prom
we all went in a group okay so yeah my
group of
friends like they all didn't have dates
so we were just like let's go dance you
know
you know what i think that's better too
because you know if you're awkward
you wouldn't go to your prom because
you're awkward but that doesn't mean you
can't go in a
group of people who are off book yeah
together
the awkward yeah yeah the awkward the
awkwardness
um yeah so i was thinking of that
and i was like you know what i i want to
write something
about that night like if i could
recreate that night what i would have
wanted
if i had the balls and just
yeah the nerve to have maybe found my
truth sooner in life
this is what i wish it would have been
and um
yeah that's important too because i mean
that
for in at last that's how you would have
designed that night for you
yeah or even have to come out even even
sooner but i felt like it's such a
pivotal night
everyone remembers it whether it's
memorable or not you know so
i i was like this is going to be like
the perfect
you know short film where we can have a
beginning middle and
end and and yeah that's how we started
you know creating the the story for that
so can you can you walk us through
uh and for people that are listening
that i'm sure we'll check out at last
um a little bit about um you creating
that
yeah so i had written the script we
sent it out to all these initiative
programs you can possibly imagine got
rejected
many many times people were like you
can't make this no one's gonna watch
this i
sent them a list of the my dream cast
they're like
ha ha no way and um i was like okay so
again always i was always you know an
underdog even in basketball so this the
competitiveness was always in my blood
so i was like all right i'm gonna
prove these people wrong uh you know
told my brother
right we're gonna make this with my
other producer friend joseph and
literally it was us you know making a
indiegogo this how we could fund it um
and going out to these uh actors so
i had seen zach and i'm very passionate
about people with disabilities
and and having a platform where they can
shine
you know and um i knew that i wanted her
best friend to have down syndrome so i
had sent
his mom the script she read it you know
called me that same day she's like i'm
in
yes like we need a story like this and
and zach
is um uh what's his last name
it's gottagan yeah yeah he's uh did the
peanut butter falcon
butter falcon yeah she's very good yeah
great shia buff yeah great actor and
and yeah then marlene was the second
person you know
and she's like girl anything you're in
you're
you're making i'm in and and
i like to write with with actors in mind
it helps with the writing so
i use their voice and um you know
trisha who plays the love interest sam i
had worked with her in a couple of
things
and then katie i we had produced a short
film she was in
and it was just this conversation i had
with her you know it's all about gut and
i had seen her
at a film festival and i was like oh my
god this is her we had a conversation
she sent me a tape and
you know this is she's gonna carry this
this this film and and yeah and then
with george you know i
i think it is really all about gut yeah
as about the gut instinct
of of a person's own personal goodness
not mine for you or you for me but
saying you have to follow it
you gotta something's telling me i need
to do this
you know yeah yeah and then you know
with george and he said yes and
it was you know tell everybody where you
saw me the first time
so he was coming out of a studio by like
marina del rey
right and my brother was driving and i
was you know we were
we were still in like pre-production
and i told him like stop the car and i
jump out and i run up to him
and i was like george george and he i
got coke all
right he's literally like going into the
car
and he he gets out and he says hi
nice to meet you you know shake hands
i'm like i'm lorena i'm
you know i'm a filmmaker i moved here
from new york i'm writing this film i
would love to work with you one day and
and i don't know if i've ever told you
this but you meet so many people here
in in hollywood and you know everyone's
like yeah you know
yeah but this guy is just
such a superstar and such a gem of a
human that
literally i it was unbelievable because
this is someone i used to watch
you know like growing up and for him to
have taken the time
to acknowledge
[Music]
hear me and just
give me that i got you
you know means the world and i don't
know how i can ever repay him for that
because um yeah it made
everything like all the hard work and
the hustle like pay off
at the end to have had him be a part of
this project i really want to tell you
go [ __ ] yourself
talking and george's role in this
if you want to tell us because i don't i
want to make sure well you don't
think what you're doing but i'm going to
say
you know
to to grow up so isolated like i did
and to
be i never knew my father my mother
didn't want me
when i was born nobody would hold me
there's no pictures of me as a baby
and you just get to this you're just
like man
nobody wants me around and
i couldn't ask for anybody's help
at all which i think is detrimental in
the in any community but especially in
ours
i mean one time in high school i went to
the dodger game with
my girlfriend's dad and two brothers and
i didn't have any money
and they were gonna buy me food and
stuff to eat and i said no
because i just couldn't even take like
are you sure you don't want to eat and i
said no i don't want anything
starving but i mean i wouldn't even say
like yeah that's cool great thank you i
appreciate that
but i didn't have any money i thought i
didn't have any value
so um
and it's a long road but
you know you've been with me more than
anybody else and i just think that
in my health and feeling better and in
my career
and achieving something that is
insurmountable like it just doesn't
happen
that ultimately the bottom line is when
you see somebody who comes to you with a
dream you don't
extinguish it you know you give them
you encourage them to to do it so when i
got out of the car as a sign of respect
to get out of the car like i never stand
get out and
when i said to you if you get this if
you get this going i'll do it
i'll do it and then i don't know how
many times you tracked it down there
because brian said how many shows did
she go through
[Laughter]
you had come to a number of shows that's
how i know you very unpleasant
you stayed on it very diligent because
it's not that i wouldn't have done it
though it's just that
i don't know man you you just see how
dedicated someone is
and when you don't go away and it wasn't
annoying you weren't annoying
and um i was just like you know what i'm
gonna tell them
and you know just to tell all the people
that i work
i'm gonna do this thing and like there's
i'm not doing it for money i'm just
gonna do it
oh okay and
so i'm gonna do it even though they
probably said like you know you don't
need to really do that
i just i felt like i wanted to do it
myself having a daughter
and and just it just seemed like
it was if i could have been that last
piece that
helps get it done i'm gonna be the i'm
gonna say yes
and you were and and i think it was
persistence
you know and i was like i hope this is
not coming off as like
i just knew you know that there was no
way
or no one else who could play this
character like it had to be george i
wrote it with him in mind like
this and when we met too i don't know if
if i've told you this but at first time
you know he
we we talked and and you know we said
our goodbyes and he gave me this hug and
it was
this hug that i have probably
er yearned from a father you know and he
just
it was this it was a powerful moment and
i i just felt the the love that
i guess i wish i would have had from my
dad my own dad
but to have seen you like this is our
like staple father figure you know and
we need to cut this part out because if
mayan hears this no
you should be like that son of a [ __ ]
where's my hug he's never hugged
[Laughter]
uh but but yeah you know so
i got there you know with my myself
uh but when i
in the late 90s when i was really in a
bad place
uh i'm not sure if i how i turned it
around i think i turned it around by
first saying i wasn't going to be
concerned with other what other people
are doing i spent so much of my
time worrying about what everybody else
was doing and you know
nobody knows if that's going to work i
just thought so much of my time is
negative about
other people in this business that is
nothing related to me which you know to
wish someone not well
or it's just it just felt like it was
poison to me so i thought
let me you know get rid of that
and then everything it's funny
everything opened up
got it got very different but when i
um you know first started showing up at
warner bros to write the show
i knew nothing about that
business and it's it's a you know it's a
big business you're warner brothers and
you know two and a half men are over
there in the er and you're right there
you know ellen
and uh and you're just like man i'm just
this little
piece but there was no way that
i wasn't gonna leave that place without
being successful like i just felt that
every day that i got up like
i'm gonna make this i'm gonna carry this
thing and i did
you know it's still on so i and that's
why i did that
with you because you really don't see a
lot of people that kind of
initiative and that kind of drive who
already have something prepared
it's usually them trying to see if
you're interested in doing something
that there's nothing to show them
yeah yeah but yeah it comes back to also
like
um like when luck meets opportunity
you know when you have to go like i we
were literally leaving like the toms
tom's like headquarters there because we
were doing a job and then like it
i feel like divine timing you know it's
all about just putting it out there to
the universe
because i would have never in a million
years had you said oh by the way you're
gonna like
you know pass him and i was like yeah no
way i just it's so great that you jumped
out
yeah both of you so great
it's pretty cool but if you don't see me
we're not here
no no way no yeah and you make the movie
we make the movie and it's and it's very
very critically acclaimed and
everything what what has that led to oh
it's led to yeah uh
film festivals it's legit which is
really
where everything that's that's like the
big party right yeah you want to be one
which unfortunately it's all been
virtual
you know we haven't been able to go to
these festivals um
we will be uh i don't know if i can say
this or not but we'll be on um
hbo september 2021 which is huge
congratulations yeah um and
yeah the feature that's what we're what
we're trying to get off the ground
beautiful or you're shooting this as a
feature yeah
you know this oh yeah that was good
though he was acting he's a great actor
well i got to do it i mean i can't yeah
and then
did any of it had to surprise you
it did because it was so hard i mean we
had lost our locations
two days like that school that we shot
in and the rooftop we didn't have
that the week that we were shooting and
literally
you know it now that we've passed that i
can look back and see
wow lorena you you and your team are
like
i don't know how you did it because
making a film is hard as it is you know
um but add that you know i mean
just losing locations losing uh we
you know uh production designers and and
yeah everything was just hard
and and but you pull through you pull
through
you pull through and you just look at
the finish line you're like i have to
get there and
and knowing that i had you know uh
george and my cast
committed you know because um one of my
producers was like what are you going to
do if you don't find a location it's
like tuesday and we're filming on friday
are you gonna call the cast and tell
them to i was like no
no like we're gonna make this movie no
matter what like we're gonna find this
location
and we're gonna make it happen there is
no plan b like [ __ ] plan b
like we're going with plan a and um
yeah just literally determination
and working your ass off and not taking
no further
and you shot it in all the equipment you
had to you had to raise money right how
much
yeah so we raised our indiegogo and we
raised like twenty thousand on indiegogo
yeah so super grateful for all our
contributors
and we had dean cundy who's worked with
spielberg
and um ron howard and you know he was
such a
little gem you know to have had and i
knew that this
this film was going to look beautiful
you know with with his
v with his eye um so yeah he was
one of our um amazing you know academy
award-winning our
academy nominated um cinematographers
and we had
um yeah an amazing um
you know costume designer and editor who
who came in
to to just shape this beautiful film and
yeah people just wanting to be a part of
of the story
and saw you know the the vision
so i am indebted to to everyone who
jumped on board and what have you heard
from people that have seen at last
uh that it's moved them you know and
they necessarily
necessarily don't have to be a part of
the community to really feel
uh impacted um and
yeah just everything from you know the
disability community of
seeing zach just be the best friend like
you know we don't
talk about his down syndrome at all it's
just what it is he is the best friend
her ride or die
um i call him flesh flash
but yeah just a beautiful i think the
the biggest compliment
was um you know we've been nominated for
several awards and my
my true honor is the the ensemble one
because it's such an ensemble piece you
know every person
you know it they're acting at like this
caliber
you know and it's you know they say
acting is reacting
right right so i think it's such a
beautiful compliment to to the entire
cast
and um yeah well you know i think it's
you know all those things that are out
there to see like this you know that
if anybody's out there that you know is
closeted and not
you know them they're afraid and to be
and to be the true self that you know
the things that
creatively inspire people that this
would be one of those things like when i
saw
cheek on the man when i was growing up
like i was that was it i was
you know i i had an occupation
and it without that i'm not sure
how many years it would have taken me to
kind of crea
to know that that was that occupation so
i learned it at
you know 13 and it it
it it stayed with me you know so so
for that yeah but i think that the more
people see this that
you know i it's a big deal for you
yeah i hope it starts a conversation and
it changes people's hearts
and yeah it's a besides also the you
know ensemble i think
another compliment is when people say i
can tell how personal this is
you know and and i think we set off to
make a john hughes-esque
you know coming-of-age film and that was
another huge you know like he's another
person that i've
whose work i've you know studied and and
i think
it is you know a little john
hughes-esque coming of each tale
yeah well what's next for
the feature the feature you have you've
been the script
yeah i have the script when does it
shoot
don't know yet i don't have a date yet
but um
it takes place in new york
you might want to have luis guzman be me
he's more new york than no yeah i want
this uh the san fernando boy
that's right it'll be interesting yeah
and uh back to my other question what
what's his role what's george's role in
this
just so people know what to expect in in
unless
in the short yes so george plays the dad
in the film um his wife is marlene forte
and and i'm very excited at the
beginning of the show
yes there's your prom and i'm just
gushing over her
and how i can't wait to walk her down
the aisle all this all the stuff that
inside she'd be like oh [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah you're gonna find the right man
i can't wait that's your problem right
now mama walking you down the aisle
without all kinds of grandkids
yeah um and then yeah at the end uh
you know our hero lauren uh
calls her dad and and reveals her
biggest darkest
secret that she's been carrying and um
i'm super excited for people to see you
in this role i don't think they've seen
really
you know just being the supportive
loving
father and and another thing i
i sent you this too um everyone saying
that
for the hispanic community and the dads
that are the macho dads you know we
this is the perfect example you know to
be like here this
is how you should react if your kid were
to
you know say something you know it is
like the the definition of like
loving unconditionally you know
unfortunately
i've seen a lot of like people
diminished and hope is diminished and
you know that time i told you that my
grandma was brutal man and my
her son brings this woman over that
he ended up marrying and she listened
who's to say what's attractive but my
grandmother was all about
first of all everybody was fat even if
you weren't fat
they're like trying to wear a fat ass
car
and she's like she's not even fat and or
her car
or her car so but my grandmother
laid into her son about the looks of the
woman that he brought over to meet
his mom and remember i told you
yeah that's rough he was just
broken and he's like am i don't say that
you know don't say that and she just
kept saying all these
horrific things about somebody who was
standing right there
with him and us right there and
you know it didn't have to break my
heart for me to realize
how callous and how insensitive and how
really
she i mean if someone doesn't
can see anyone else's joy they're not
going to see their own
but it was one of those days in my life
that it just really
it it was devastating to them
because you can't take that stuff back
and really devastating to me to see
somebody who was raising me be so
uh evil to someone and especially one of
our own sons
so um that's why i think that
all of this is just it's just very good
and i'm proud like you know i tell you
i'm proud of you it's hard for you to
get a hold of me now
because i'm in quarantine but
you know you know it means so much for
me to see you
um get what's deserved to you because
of all the different ways that
you had to go to get even here
so yeah i'll do the feature yeah i know
and and thank you you know i always try
to offer we got right there
i always try to keep him posted and you
know let him know
because i know you know some people and
that's another thing about george you
know some people
go into the job and then like that's it
like peace out you know but this guy has
been
you know just from start to where we are
now
still you know involved so thank you
well crazy is that amazing how people
think i'm an [ __ ] i kind of am but
i'm not
getting that
i don't think anybody sees the kindness
we were talking about that last week
that there's so much negativity towards
me and towards me as a latino really
awful thing said and i'm almost 60 like
you
you know we were talking last week like
you think we're in high school that
people take their time out of their
lives to
try to attack me when yeah it's more
it's it makes their day apparently yeah
but
so inspirational i mean so i mean you're
a person who had nothing except for your
own
will to make it happen and it happened
and it's happening it's it's really
really inspiring
so great to have you here because i met
you a couple times and i'm like oh she's
so nice and he's very kind i didn't know
you were just
brilliant do you think you'll get
nominated for academy award
i hope so i hope the film i mean it's
been getting recognized you know
with oscar quality festival so you know
that i'm in
i do know that yeah when they couple
years ago
when they wanted to add people
they added they added some
african-american people and latino
people and i'm in the academy
wow wow so you get to vote and you know
what i do i walk in there
tip over all the punched or crackers
when they have a screening
fire alarm fat no i hate the bad kid but
it's powerful to be able to
to vote oh my god you know that boat
wasn't there before yeah
yeah well i wish you i mean i love you
so much i wish you the best
and uh how can people see it is there is
a way people see the short
so as of right now i know we're playing
the cleveland international film
festival april 8th
i don't know if this is going to be out
before then or after um
but uh yeah it's playing april 8th and
people can follow us on instagram at
last short film that's where we're
constantly posting you know upcoming
festivals
and you're other than that you're going
to have to wait till september 2021
on hbo max hbo max
yeah brilliant that's when i had a dream
i was dating
mia farrell yeah this is true by the way
i did have a dream like i was dating me
okay
okay and her apartment had the highest
ceilings by 150 feet up in here
yeah thank you lorraine for coming thank
you so much very inspiring
i loved it
[Music]
does it seem like it was that hard now
that you look back
yeah yeah really still so it makes
all of this like just so rewarding and
that's all well-played you know in the
beginning i would i would uh
at the beginning of my show i would get
very emotional
because because it was all brand new to
me
and i'm going to give you some really
good advice
because i i got wrapped up into thinking
that everybody there that worked there
that came back every year
120 weeks were family
and the thing that
was the most devastating to me was when
you realize that
to them it's just a job oh yeah so
don't ever get to where you think
like emotionally attached to yeah
because they don't give a [ __ ]
yeah and the minute it was over and
sometimes they left to do other things
and you realize that i didn't have a
family so you're trying to make
that place of family and even though
they're like yeah boss
this is a family no it's not
not to appreciate what they do but not
to buy
in to the whole thing like hey we're
just one big happy family
yeah we weren't
okay and with that cheerful they're
gonna say you're not trying to make
friends
you're trying to get shows done yeah
and we're going on a show called the
jennifer horrible
the the popping of the kansas i'm sure
it sounds great you're on the
podcaster's
ears all right well it's time for the
news let's do the news right now we've
got a few stories
i think we'll like this one first one
from the bbc i'm into it
that dude is the worst person in the
world
what school did you go to what school
did you actually go to where you learned
how to read
i went to uh friends in kindergarten was
the first
that's what it was called
no he was foreign leave naked a close
show up like 10 o'clock at night oh your
son left this here his whole outfit
he had a little swagger to him when he
left okay
this one's from the bbc slow walkers are
more likely to die
still study fine from covin it says uh
kovid studiers say slow walkers are more
likely to die than brisk walkers
health researchers based uh conclusion
that slow walkers with a normal weight
were 3.75 times more likely to die from
the virus than brisk walkers
so if you're a person who just chills
and walks lower
you're at more risky as a new yorker
you go farts and you walk away and if
you if you just linger
you're right in it right that's what it
says they said uh
uh walk pace could be used to predict
whether someone was
at a higher risk from the virus i
couldn't tell you how many times my
grandmother told me she was gonna kill
me if i didn't keep
up so so
slow walking was considered to be at a
speed less than three miles per hour
whatever that is
and and then three to four miles per
hour uh a brisk
so the virus attacks gordos or people
with a lower
i think one hand in hand with the other
people who walk fast are normally in
better shape but you can tell
just by seeing someone walking down the
road whether they're high risk or low
risk of catching
or dying from it have you ever seen a
fatty
pick up the pace when the food's ready
that's right
those are when he's the least
susceptible to catch the coven
when he's chasing a burrito like if you
if marine calendars has
the all-you-can-eat pie
oh my i'm right there but yeah so a
little tip yeah right just did
i don't know really why they even made
the study but interesting that just by
looking at someone walking down the
street and i don't know how they figured
out because they don't include that in
the article
but they say people who walk slow and
just chill just like
are more likely to die from coving it'll
catch you oh wow i'll catch you that's
yeah it doesn't seem like it doesn't
seem like that would be why because when
they walk they have to hold
on to things like you touch the rail you
got it that's a great that's probably
what it is
you lean on the wall oh my god touching
your face
touching your face you know yeah
i'm guessing i'm guessing when you go
like that to look in the bakery or
they're making bread you're like
now you touch your nose up and against
the windows you got it fat
are you already taking things off the
window yeah
so what's the last time you heard
someone's awesome and fatso
1974. that's so loud man i'll get you
you know what my first game is
in high school 1974
okay lopez they put fatso back there
brilliant all right uh from radio.com
uh pastor heals people by farting in
their faces
this is a real story where is this
uh yeah this is from rio.com from our
lady i've pulled my finger
this is from south africa south africa
um did i just smell my fats yeah
so the pastor farts in people's
faces a south african pastor claims that
he can heal people by farting on their
faces
yeah that dude's got a fetish
uh chris penelope i'm under the robe
[Laughter]
forgive me father chardonnay it's been
two days as my last shard
uh yeah yeah he says start some people's
faces in their faces
if i if i was sitting in a wheelchair
and somebody came over and popped one
out of my face i might stand up and walk
it's a miracle with one eye just
feel watery a faith healer
it smells like hell uh yeah he
uh is uh chris penelope is a
self-proclaimed man go to that church
that they're just
everybody in line well see we don't have
to photograph those but it has been
photographed sitting on top of people's
faces and farting on them now that's
that's yeah that's inquiring minds um
pinellas says he just
has to fart on their heads near their
nostrils
[Laughter]
to release the holy spirit oh my god
man i'm going to use that one my wife oh
man
honey i swear to god this works listen
we want things to change in our life
here
come over here oh god get your
announcements right here
uh one of his seminars there were dozens
of people waiting to receive the holy
farts onto their faces
some people have had to wait up to two
months to meet with penelope
to get farted on others don't get to
meet with them but collected
you come to your senses
so you come to your center you're going
to call hello hi this is george
hey you just moved up on the list man
tomorrow uh the pastor's ready to fart
on your phone
great what time uh you always plan on
having a salisbury steak tonight with
some hard-boiled eggs and some sunny
delight
and some old english 800. so if you get
there by like 6 45 when you get
something they'll be right back
make sure you get a little mix to clear
yourself
take a big breath
but like i said the last others don't
get to meet with him but collect his
farts in containers
and take them with them oh no how would
that happen you're trying to fart in a
little bottle like
i hold it in there i guess they try to
collect it in containers or not like
that
that's what i'm imagining sweeping it in
there a little bit back in the middle
now you go over you take your little
container
like to the u-haul where you can get
propane 24 hours a day you just go to
the dude's house knock out the window
you give you take the tank from them
and he gives you another tank and that
one has sparks in it and he fills
there's a little fart in there uh all
right move right along this is a crazy
world man yeah
can you believe some dude really and
people buy it people think that's the
holy spirit coming out of history
they're actually buying it like paying
for it literally i think they are
well they're donating to the church i'm
guessing that's how it works
and they and he sits on their face over
their face
and farts in their nostrils holy water
with some bubbles in them
[Laughter]
insider.com reports that uh there's a
new app that allows you to escape zoom
meetings by playing unbearable sounds
no way yeah you know that problem that
everybody has right like hey
i got something in the background i
gotta get out of here so there's an app
for that
so it says an app developer has come up
with a nifty and somewhat devious
solution to help people duck out of
boring zoom calls
zoom escaper is a free web widget that
allows
users to add fake audio effects to a
zoom call making it so annoying for uh
the other participants that they might
end the call
oh wow yeah yeah according to the
article
play button number one
yeah he says i've been thinking about
how to sabotage
uh work in uh digital context especially
one we're
the means of production are also
personal devices that mediate your
social life
so this guy's thinking that it's like a
big you know problem for him to get on
this thing so now he just jumps off it
amazing some lazy dude that's trying to
get out of work that's exactly what it
is
uh can you tell me that hey you come and
eat you know they record it and sell it
yeah audio effects range in spanish
i gotta go now right they range from
scraping sound of chopping connection
uh uh to broken up words and
incomprehensible
gibberish other noises available on the
application to annoy one's co-workers
and fury collaborators include a crying
baby
a man weeping loudly the incessant
barking of a dog
and continuous construction so that
might work
which are the ones that will get you
let's see the dog barking i hate dogs
parking yeah i was thinking that you
went in
that's a tough one drives me out of my
mouth yeah i'm my own dog
out of the zoom right yeah get you out
baby crying
everybody yeah like i got it i got a
deal
your wife ovulating
[Laughter]
i'm out she makes it on her own calls
yeah that's uh but you know the guy's
making money off it already
so what is it called again the app it is
called uh zoom escaper
zoom escaper yeah you can look it up
online yeah we should probably look it
up see what face let's pick it up yeah
and we got is it an app or is it it
says zoom escaper is a free web widget
widget he's an app developer
and um he created by an artist named sam
levine l-a-v-i-g-n-e
and uh this is how you get out of them i
had a corned beef tonight tonight
i have no idea what that means
i'm pretending i don't know what that
means
um oh where you got it i think this is
it
anything because uh my wife has had to
get off on
on zoom stuff just because there's stuff
in in my house
it was almost 2 am shall go some beer
before they close
huh i don't know she started listening
to these so i have no idea what you're
talking about
last caller get her out of there
last call start the car here uh here's
an
here's an okay la article from whdh.com
which we get a lot of stuff from
uh this man waiting on final paycheck
from
ex-employer gets 500 pounds of oily
pennies dumped in his driveway
how about that what do you mean
a man waiting on a final paycheck from
his ex-employer gets 500 pounds of oily
pennies dumped in his driveway
like he was just bitching about his
money and then yeah oh yeah
yeah like this oily penny oily like
yeah a man uh who was waiting on his
final paycheck from his disgruntled
ex-employer got quite the surprise when
500 pounds of oil-covered pennies
were reportedly dumped in the driveway
in the middle of the night
how about that uh andres flatten of
georgia
filed his two weeks notice in november
but his boss at walker luxury
luxury motors uh was upset by the
development
apparently he froze and stared at me for
like a straight minute flat and told the
news outlet
he gets up puts his hands on his head
walks out the door and disappears that's
that's what happened when he quit
wow so uh so
flatten reportedly left the job due to a
toxic work environment but walker
claimed that the 950
915 bucks that we still owed him would
be delivered in january
so they had a dispute over it when the
money failed to arrive fladden contacted
the georgia department of labor
months later 504 pounds of oily pennies
were dumped in his driveway
women i got two chores on it or her
peanuts i don't know how they got them
oily
that's a question mark flattens
girlfriend shared a video of the massive
pile of coins
showing her oil-coated hands as she
picked them up
asked about the pennies walker told the
news outlet that he couldn't recall if
he had dumped the coins
he's like i might it could have been me
i'm not really sure
he got paid that's all that matters it's
good to know people can still play
stupid and
it still works i don't know oh how about
this flatten says he is currently
working to clean the penny so he can
cash them in
oh my gosh is pretty important
best part of that last line okay wow
yeah does anybody want any pennies
anymore even though it's still money
nobody really
especially have they smell like pebbles
i remember when we were young and and
went to the movies and i
i had rolls of pennies it was like it
was i guess it would have been eight
bucks or something behind the green door
exactly with pennies it goes to an adult
uh stag boy a little porno
that was a little embarrassing sir so my
brother was behind me
and i paid in pennies and they're like
looking at me like are you serious and i
gave them all pennies right and
guess what my brother gave him a 20. the
game was changed in
my pen
[Laughter]
on any sunday right that's when stuff
doesn't work out that way
uh i'm looking for the one my favorite
one uh in here
real quick that i didn't see early
it's it's when i was laughing nobody
uses paper anymore by the way
you take your time oh we're missing the
one we're missing all right that's okay
which one
it was octopus teacher it was no when
the guys uh have you seen the octopus
teacher
no i think this dude makes love to a
squid and
then every time it goes to the water
they they hook up
how about that and then he doesn't show
up for like a month and she throws black
ink all over him like she's all pissed
off
trying to scratch his car just throw his
ink at him
the guy's like having a relationship
with octopus in the in the ocean
like they reach out they touch and then
he comes back
and wraps around his wrist
and then the other one comes back
don't go anywhere i'll be back sunday
and then through like like four years
they hook up like he buys her a little
blouse octopus blouse
oh my god oh my god
that's funny but she got pissed off when
he didn't show up and she inked them
oh my gosh okay uh i can she inked them
is that what they do they ink and then
yeah it's a
incredible documentary of okay
like how does a it must be lonely in the
ocean if though
if an octopus sees a man and it's like
oh my date's here
octavia your dates here i see his ankles
in the water
oh my god his ankles this is this is the
one that i was talking about a little
earlier today is how the body of an
arizona great grandmother ended up as
part of a u.s army blast test
okay so i i said i don't have it in
front of me i just looked it up online
right now but um
uh what happened was she donated her
body to sign you know she donated her
body parts well
her grandson finally found out that they
donated her body
to uh bomb testing and they blew her
body up i mean they
they yeah i'm just obviously her family
hoped doris stauffer's body would be
used to study alzheimer's
the story of how she became a pentagon
i like to donate my my grandma's body
it'll be done to alzheimer's right
i don't i don't i i'm sorry she got
banged
i can't remember why i could tell
today's gonna be next wednesday at 10
o'clock
i'm so sorry los alamos testing facility
right there oh my god
on the way into vegas by peppy parker's
chicken
at the body and clyde car can you
imagine that oh man i'm so sorry i'm
laughing anyways
the story of what they put her in her
grandma clothes like her little shoes
her favorite shoes horrible
and her knitting and 10.
can you imagine that's just got to be
the most horrific thing story of how she
became the subject of a pentagon
experiment cast a spy
on a growing and unregulated industry
human body brokers
so uh it's a very long thing but what
had happened
uh is that he thought the son thought
she was going to be in a study
and i don't know she was in a study and
they blew her up
her brain was never used for alzheimer's
research instead stafford's body became
part of an army experiment that measured
damage caused by roadside bombs oh
that's horrible i'm so sorry i laughed
earlier i didn't say i
could have put her uniform with a helmet
we didn't forget it was like i think
it's the ball thing like that
the password why is that beef
oh that's horrible okay sorry sorry
sorry that's hard man that's awful man
yeah i know they're blowing people up
yeah without saying that they're
brokering bodies now so once you donate
your body you really don't have any
control of where it's going
that's a there were a couple chicanos
that broke into forest lawn a long time
ago
and they were having sex with the people
in there oh for real yeah
like when you all hope is gone like like
they they
like no kidding
give them the high cold one oh that's a
rough one
they did they caught they you know those
guys were they don't
see cameras or anything what about that
what about when i try to experiment on
monkeys the monkeys get smart like
i wanted to give it a shot they have
long arms and they reach in the
monkey they go for the balls to go first
yeah and he grabs you
a little hell you got the little shot
this monkey
[Laughter]
hey man listen the way the way that we
treat animals
you know it's horrible especially
trolling you know all that the stuff
the hair spray all that makeup yeah
right
you know you know you put makeup on
there's a little pink knuckle in there
oh hey now but it smells delicious it's
sexy you get your makeup at the swap
meet
does this make up the us estee lauder
yeah but yeah
you might find a couple of bones in
there but yeah
nail polish okay all right
that's good uh okay uh finally i just
kind of want to know what you think but
you know when you donate your body to
science like
you don't ask what they're going to do i
guess not
i don't have any control right i mean i
don't remember when i
what about you airplane with the gold
dead grandma
on just to see what it is you fly into
the kids like you know
a birthday party it's like weekend at
bernie's kind of thing
she's like she made the party when you
laugh
okay
[Music]
but okay moving on okay uh well as we
all know i just kind of wanted because
if
you donated they go what are you gonna
do with her just like hey you know what
that's not your concern anymore
yeah because you you know you signed
that paper yeah
that's it i'm gonna dance with her watch
turn the music up
like hey that's my grandmother you
signed the paper watch out my dipper
dentures come out oh
that's nice anyway the wall street
journal.com
is just uh reporting that the miami
beach declared state of emergency to
reduce spring
break and i just kind of i saw like
those videos
isn't that amazing what is listen this
country
when the police are arresting somebody
everybody's twerking oh by the cops it's
become a thing now
we were talking about that on the videos
right every five feet you see a girl
twerking to get make sure she's on
tick-tock and doing
videos yeah everybody's going for it
it's social media crazy
so now you're like help me today hey
hey uh yeah it's kind of when you were
in college did you go to spring break
yes i did i only went two minutes ago
i'm sure
i'm sure you were the belle of the ball
yeah well i tell you i was
slaying them down there in mexico and i
i went to uh
rosarito beach and it's a big spring
break place
that's like zero [ __ ] right yeah yeah
yeah but they had cheap lobsters that's
what they were pumped
up somebody down put that corner
and nothing went well at that time i
twisted my ankle i felt on a flight
and then when i left it had been i drove
all the way to roseville beach
and when i left they had been painting
the building red
the roof ran out my car had red polka
dots
that was the only
[Laughter]
you guys didn't do the prep kick that's
what all these rolls are for
you cover the car up and it bleeds into
[ __ ]
that's how my grandfather painted he was
playing in the house
and then his nephew's painted all the
windows shut like they made sure the
paint went in the crease
oh my god they made sure it went and
then i go what if there's a fire he's
like you go out a lot already
yeah [ __ ] your fire trap it's locked
shut down it's painted shut you're never
gonna open that window
oh my god ah i'm trying to get a few
painted shirt windows it's impossible
that guy wasn't a priest over there
farting on my head in the bedroom
trying to get some friend chair
[Laughter]
friendship that's what my uncle used to
say hey man
i'm gonna go outside what's going on i
feel good i just need a glass i got some
french air
friendship yeah it's awesome we never
corrected them
great and that's our news uh
let's uh move on to some voicemails
that people actually call we're gonna
have to put our headphones on but uh
is the number if you want to ask george
some questions or advice what is it
again
818-533-1843
all right you could be on the show
we're good that's here and here's our
first one
what if it was a rabbit
you know someone's going to do this
before it's over someone's going to make
some unnecessary sounds on the wall hey
mr lopez this is your topic
here in las cruces new mexico uh
i just want to say thanks for coming out
here and showed you that film a couple
years back
um walking with her my question that i
had for you
um it's actually i guess like a two-part
question the first part is
when was the first time and who was the
first
person that you were struck with and
um the second part is who are you most
or who's the most recent person you have
still been star struck even though
you're a celebrity yourself
i know that maybe there might be in a
time when you're like wow like i'm still
seeing this guy but anyway
thanks for everything you're doing in
the latin community i'm not doing it
like about
the whole community thank you hope you
hear from me
let me hope to hear from you i will call
them up you're walking with herb
um i have a couple votes oh
for you uh my guesses let's hear him
um he said first person i'm gonna say
and i don't want to start anything i
won't start no [ __ ]
but uh i think eric estrada was one of
the first people you actually saw
that star structured all right that's a
good very good and then
i would just shake his hand he didn't
shake my hand yeah
and um and
remember that time we were in the car
before the first hbo special i said
hey man when i was growing up i started
to shake my hand
i should say that in the special and i
did and i and that was i love that
the beginning of it right oh yeah and
look at you now and the special after
that i think it's special after that
so one time i went to ralph's on water
and ventura and there was a cholo there
marking the bread you know putting the
bread on the shelves
and he's like hey guess what yesterday i
said who
called erica i said oh yeah and this guy
starts laughing like what was he doing
he was there buying dale brady and then
the dude said take it easy on me you won
man
[Laughter]
i said in his radio rolls royce [ __ ]
40 years ago he goes yeah
yeah and i also vote for the last one
i have a vote for uh i don't know i'm
jeremy am i dressing with you i get mine
exactly right he jumped up and this
thing came out anyway um
i'm guessing uh sir uh paul mccartney
at coachella coachella that was one way
it just seemed like you were you thought
it was very cool i mean you're not
very cool yeah yeah um well i mean
yeah we know everybody i mean there's
some huge names can i take a guess yeah
good one
prince oh
prince was one yeah and you became
friends though great friends of prince
though which is
really interesting but i think um
i don't know i mean i testified in the
michael jackson trial in 2005
and to see michael jackson in there
looking like a nutcracker oh he went
straight from fall schwartz to the
courtroom
he looked like a straight up nutcracker
man wow
my line that i got ellen i said he
looked like the captain antonio both
i think that when you walk into a
courtroom you don't expect
that when you're sitting on the witness
stand that
literally maybe 10 feet from you is
going to be
one of the most famous people in the
world yeah
so i think prince michael jackson
uh dalai lama oh yeah how to miss that
one
that's big so i like that but
i think i don't know i'm still such a
huge fan of of people bruce springsteen
that time that i went to go see him and
the first time i didn't say hello and
then the second time i didn't think i
was going to be able to say hello
and then as i was going in his guy said
hey
uh at the end stay in your seat and i'll
bring you back like that
even though i met him a couple times
that's still a big thing and i wasn't a
fan like
in high school when born to run came out
but then that one sunday when he did
like eight shows in l.a and we went to
the last show
and we got tickets that day so we're in
the last row and i mean you see this guy
really just
amazing oh incredible i was been a fan
for life so to see him is always
it's always good and uh who else elton
john
elton john yes it's a big one and uh
and the head george is in the crowd
in vegas elton john stops the show and
wishes george a happy birthday which he
never stops he never doesn't know wow
really really cool that was awesome
that's a big deal
and he kissed me on the lips so
three dudes three dudes have kissed me
on the lips
wait four four four sorry brian yeah i'm
in there ralph paul
right there uh brian eddie van halen
elton john and carlos santana it's a
good list
except for brian the only one trying to
give me the tongue and it's right there
[Laughter]
is there any more is there yeah i think
we got a plenty more we got right
let's cue up number two uh hello um this
is bad i was just
um listening to your podcast and enjoyed
it and i was wondering
would you ever work with eric estrada
would she just listen is this live
where
no i wouldn't work with eric estrada
really like if he
if he came out i was like hey man this
is let's just put by guns be you know
he's not gonna do that we're gonna throw
chingaso
if we ever see each other in person
again it's going down eh
you know that right yeah i i know uh i
was
that there was a meeting there was a
meeting right
i was having a shoulder shoulder george
and we're at
a school function or a fundraiser and
we're shoulder shoulder
george like look at this look look over
there and it was
him no it was and he looked over and
then george gave the full-on
yeah and then here he got and then of
course now now we're in
and he did nothing and then he went on
the radio and said he wanted to take a
swing at me
no and i called him a hindsight badass
and
if he ever wanted to take a shot at me
i'd
knock the rest of those veneers down his
throat
[Laughter]
could go to dr beacham and pico rivera
get a replacement
but but we were treated very nicely that
day [ __ ] yeah man
and i i believe it was his wife who put
it all together so it was a very she was
great
we get edited so no the answer is no
excellent hi george oh my god hi
i hope i did that um so the grammys just
why it's so hard to say oh my god
and a big thing that came out of it was
cardi b
and megan d stallion's performance of
her song walk
and it's always been controversial for
some reason ever since the beginning of
the song debuting
but her performance really you know put
the cherry on top and upset some people
um and then of course her fans such as
myself don't care we think it's a good
song and so i'm just curious
what is your stance on the song do you
think it's controversial do you think
it's
too racy too steamy um you know
other men rappers in the past have
released steamy and racy
songs and so do you think there's a
double standard there so just what is
your overall thoughts on what
and cardi b do you like where to be do
you not think it's that one question not
10.
[Laughter]
um what do you think cardi b it's a
little bit it's a little
it's almost like two live crew yeah uh
females because i was just with luther
yeah right
um because you know men have the right
like she said they have the right to do
all the videos yeah there is a double
standard just in general in the music
industry absolutely i believe
and um i would just think you know what
first of all the grammys the grammys
they know what they're doing
and they know it's not going to be that
wasn't they didn't surprise anybody
um so
i say it's all part of the it's all part
of the business yeah
i endorse people uh that's the
but it's really great some pornographic
like
on that thing right just for kids and
stuff like that
it's out there so if you have kids and
stuff like that like
i don't know man it's tough to keep like
i would always say
once they see it they can't unsee it so
you want them to not see it
or south park which is i think is great
or american
family american guy family guy family
guy and that kind of stuff that's a
little bit edgy like
you know you can see the difference in
the behavior of kids when
i remember mine was watching family guy
in south park and you could just
in her the things that she would laugh
at which
changes them i think at a young age it's
almost like
it prepares you for another brand of
comedy at earlier age but you know
um with music and stuff like that
but the production people knew it was
coming yeah i mean it had to be like
you have to rehearse all of that yeah
right so it wasn't she just didn't do
that just out of the blue right
they knew yeah so there's a little bit
more people to
to raise your eyebrows than just her you
know but um
you know as you get older as you get
older
[Music]
you know i think you're you know
my musical tastes changed like i
wouldn't really necessarily
even know who the top five
singers are right now because it's a
different just a different
genre and as kids come up they're
attracted you know the younger people
are
attracted to finding the music that
identifies
them so as someone you know
who's almost 60 i still
look to the music that i identified
myself with and it was
that was forever ago forever
who do you like um i have a great
appreciation for music like all genres
like my brother got me into music so i
love like
you know like you know 70s 80s
yeah like even even some like jazz and
i just appreciate all genres i don't
think there was a bad you know everybody
says you know the 70s was a great
the 70s was a great period of music like
i told you that i
i heard tear the roof off the sucker
parliament flashlight
um back in love again
ltd yeah brick house and at that time
all the elton john songs
were a little bit different than in the
80s when again they ended van halen
that kind of rocked that nugent kiss and
then in the 80s it got more
um you know duran duran
yeah that was pretty cool more european
sound and more european and the english
bead and the cure
and that kind of stuff and then and the
hair bands and stuff the hair bands
toward the end of the 80s and then
in the 90s like kind of
in the early 80s and then in the 90s it
really kind of found it's
what arsenio hall show i think was oh
yeah they huge
nwa and vanilla eyes and hammer and and
and big rappers like that but and then
it went pop like in the 2000s
oh yeah and poppy yeah well who do you
like what's the the most recent
artist that you anybody now oh anyone
now
i struggle now that's a that's a hard
question yeah me too i go back like you
said i go back to like
i can tell you my i just got my kirk
cameron album in the mail
hey man that's consolidation it's called
our lord
[Laughter]
you're healed my shoulder doesn't hurt
anymore
all right you got another one right on
number
i was just three or four
hi george my name is steve and
love your alcoholic just curious when
you dream do the people speak in spanish
or english thanks that's quite a
question though
from obviously white dude huh
have some race that's some he wants to
know about your dreams
my dirty dreams are all in spanish i
know
uh exactly is that a legit question is
that guy just
well i mean we can make it like are you
having a laugh
we can um
i think i no i i think i treatment i
think people think i'm way more mexican
than i really am
he's just doubting himself right now hey
man listen i'm
33 native americans so if you excuse me
i got to get to simon well
um there's a martini waiting for me as a
slobber they thought they were very
disappointed when they when my dna
results came out
um i dream in english
i also want to say that i had my house
cleared out of spirits as well before we
wrap this show
which is because we're talking about all
the spirits so grant i had somebody come
over yesterday
and clear out uh the evil spirits from
my house
and there was quite a bit of them no
from the 20s that to me was scarier than
seeing
and hearing all the sounds that he has
the woman who cleared it out
freaked me out i told him today i've
been thinking about all day
so we'll put some videos i don't know if
i won't we can we can
pixel later i think or just use the
audio but
yeah and you know it's funny because i
had my
i had my opinions on
where it was and who it was and hers was
the same as mine
without us even really knowing each
other oh wow
that above the living room in that crawl
space that looks like an attic
that they may have put the kids in there
to be punished and that's why
that rattling comes from there and also
underneath by the front door
they might have put them in there as
punishment but also a lot of the things
that i have in my house belong to people
that are no longer living so i believe
that
a couple of them came because they were
attached to some of the things that
that's crazy or were friends and they
that they were in there as well but
there was a lot
of what that a lot not just what you
think
like oh i'll just i'll burn some sage
and it'll be gone no it took
it took a couple of hours and then last
night was the
first time that i was in there overnight
uh since it was done and i'm going to
tell you like
it just feels different it feels
it's hard to say like if you went into a
place that
you now i guess you wouldn't know if it
was clear enough but just into a place
where you don't assume that anything's
in there
i had that for the first time in seven
and a half years
that it felt like the first time i went
home
that it's because nobody there but it
just feels clearer
and empty but it doesn't feel a little
bit gloomy because
those faces started to show up in the
images on the
pictures and that's when i said because
i was going to kind of leave it
if they were just making noise but when
i started to see
those faces in the reflection of those
pictures in my room
we saw that one that sent you that green
face one and we'll put them up there so
people look creepy
and when i saw that one i was like okay
this i gotta i gotta get oh god so there
is such a thing though there's someone
you could hire to get rid of all the
spirits in your house imagine if i would
have hired that priest just kind of
in every room it's gonna cost you two
burritos
sleeping outside
[Laughter]
[Applause]
do we have any more do you want to do
we're good i think that's it
another fantastic lorena gordon is so
such a pleasure to have you in thank you
commissioner gordon's daughter
oh by the way one last thing uh you know
uh uh the name of your movie
at last of course yeah and you know the
the person who co-wrote that
was matt gordon yes i did that while we
were clearing the song
um everyone's like did you name it
because of the song yeah i was like no
it was like at last she's finally her
her true self so
but very cool who's matt gordon i don't
know who that is
well we started billy holiday by the way
but i mean it's this really famous song
obviously that song tequila
and that's how you find out because i
didn't know at first when i when i read
this dude he's all about also okay
anyways
i'm gonna i am right now i can't end the
show anyways
love you all thank you everybody for you
guys thank you lorena and uh
i wish you continued success you have a
bright bright future ahead of you not
not you
this is it oh please keep leaving
voicemails
at 818-533-1843 please
and thank you
you